Filipino activists say it's a
catastrophe in the making for a country
where Millions depend on the Seas and
they're warning that Japan's decision
could prove costly
and you're talking about the Philippines
how many days it will arrive it's almost
instant you don't know the flow of the
water once you have put it in it's there
assurances by both the Japanese
government and the un's nuclear Watchdog
the retreated radioactive water being
released poses no harm have failed to
convince Skeptics
in the South Korean capital police
arrested student protesters who stormed
the Japanese Embassy in Seoul the South
Korean government is urging the Japanese
to be open and honest about what's being
done
our government hopes and urges the
Japanese government to continue to
transparently and responsibly disclose
information throughout the process of
discharge that will continue for the
next 30 Years
remarks out of Beijing have not been as
measured China reiterated its opposition
by summoning Japan's Ambassador
such an act blatantly shifts the risk of
nuclear pollution to the neighboring
countries including China and the
International Community putting its own
interests above the long-term well-being
of people in the region and around the
world it is extremely selfish and
irresponsible
photo right it's a sentiment shared by
Chinese people especially workers in the
seafood industry
how could it not have any effect on us
if it didn't then why would they
discharge it into the Open Sea can they
just keep it in their own country
in the future we will avoid importing
these raw materials from Japan we might
consider using ingredient s from Russia
instead we need to firmly boycott
Japanese products in the future
Chinese governments done just that
imposing a blanket import ban on
Japanese Marine Products within hours of
the Wastewater release
Manila Bay behind me here is around 3
000 kilometers from Fukushima but people
here and all the way to Pacific island
nations are concerned because they say
water pollution has no boundaries
find below Al Jazeera Manila
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera